let's go to our friend who we have not
heard from for so long
eric from cancun eric welcome
to
martial arts and i tried to apply it for
politics
you applied for politics what does that
mean
um let me explain first of all i do
martial arts because it's a sport and i
want to keep my muscles very strong and
very agile when i do the case and
also the flips
also because
i needed to protect myself when it's
dangerous
nothing wrong with that
okay
and also that my foot tells me that you
need a balance between it's a way to
learn how to beat violin without being
aggressive
my teacher tells me that we gotta
control our impulses and that would be a
healthy way to
to go again
against those impulses that we have
between us an inner monster that you
need to control because if you restrain
yourself too much then you become very
weak and cowardly but if you don't
restrain at all you become a jerk
so the if if i understand eric what
you're suggesting is
martial arts is a good outlet to know
when and to what degree to use violence
but to be able to control it when it
should be controlled is that
um right kinda because we gotta say that
we have our inner demons but also our
inner angels and it would be to know
when to let them let them know and when
to restrain them
well i think you're making some very
good points this is what you said this
is wisdom from your martial arts teacher
um canada but also with myself my
teacher hates bully says he's not gonna
train anyone who wants to use violence
to do whatever they want
i like that i like that listen eric how
is cancun these days is the is the
tourism industry of flourishing
currently in cancun
[Music]
my
um
and
here's going to be the part of politics
and martial arts okay there's a show in
netherlands called korakai which has the
original castle of karachiki yes and
here's in the first part johnny lawrence
he's the origin the guy who call us
against the tournament it's against
daniela russo the one who got taken in
the face he went to reopen kobrakai
because he has three rules strike first
striker and no mercy right now they
sound like rules
but in his context strike first means to
seize the moment like when you want to
grab the last box of crazy greens from
the store
strike heart is to give your best effort
i know mercy is to not give up when you
have the chance to win all right eric
from cancun you have said it all thank
you so much for the call my friend
okay thank you very much there's eric i
know eric always has more material but
at some point we have to say
that is it